to call me a cobbler is not an insult at
all it's just incorrect so totally
different like art form or craft
cobblers are the people that repair your
shoes they don't actually make them from
scratch so people that make them from
scratch will use a fancy word besides
shoemaker you can call them a cord
winner
I started making custom shoes when I was
about 16 years old I started like
painting Nike dunks and whatnot wasn't a
very good painter so I moved off and
that started playing with like fabric
which led me to the reconstructions and
then as I got better and better that it
you know just kind of naturally
progressed into making my own shoes
totally from scratch yeah like all kinds
of leather it's totally been with the
client once you know some people want
exotics like alligator Python or shark
skin or something like that other people
are more understated they just want like
a nice vegetable tanned leather or goat
skin or something like that I use all
kinds of stuff just depends what the
client wants
Oh shark skin I think has such a cool
texture to it and you never see it
my prices started $1,000 and go up from
there depending on the complexity the
design and the materials used takes at
least like 12 hours to do one pair from
scratch but that can go up you know
quite a bit hours very quickly just add
on the detail of the design and
materials you're working with just a lot
of variables you know you have to do it
yourself I think that's part of anything
that's art you have to actually get your
hands dirty you have to think about it
you know you're creating something where
there was nothing so I think it's really
art would be a mindset right of creating
something new and original that you
haven't seen out there before so as long
as you're doing that you know you can
apply that mindset to anything and then
you're do it you're making art right
this if you're making cool for
people to consume its art I think the
only personal favorites on color gray
but gray with the e